there's a war in Ukraine now it's been
going on over a year
it's uh for me personally giving my life
uh stories is is a as a deeply personal
one and I'm
returning back to that area of the world
that was there
uh Vladimir zielinski said he doesn't
want to talk to uh to Vladimir Putin
do you think they could get in a room
together
and uh
say you were there in a room with Putin
and zelenski and Biden is uh sitting in
the back drinking a cocktail or maybe he
is at the table participating how how is
it possible through negotiation through
the art of conversation to find peace in
this very tense geopolitical
uh conflict
I think it's eminently possible I think
the getting people together in person
has always been a good idea now how many
times who's getting them together under
what circumstances and how many times
you're getting them together
the um
the documentary the human factor about
the Mideast peace negotiations mostly
through the 90s mostly into the Clinton
administration
got kicked off uh under Bush 41.
and then the documentary continues
through Trump
but just touching basically on it but
they're getting air fat and and the
different Israeli Prime Ministers
together in person
and these guys do not want to talk to
each other and depend upon the prime
minister
you know the the mere thought of being
on the same planet with Arafat was
offensive
and they started getting these guys
together in parts and regularly and they
started seeing each other's human beings
and I started realizing that there was
enough room on a planet for him
and that people dying
was stupid
and they were and they would slowly work
things out by getting these guys
together in person
so how long does it take who's hosting
it but it's a good idea but the skill of
uh achieving that thing that you talk
about a lot which is empathy and I would
say in that case not just empathy but
empathy plus a bit you might disagree
with this but a drop of compassion in
there but my compassion compassion is
helpful
um but it's not essential
like if if you just know where I'm
coming from
like it it the thought the feeling of
being
understood yeah pardon understood that's
powerful is yeah and and again I know I
picked the vast majority of this up on
on Andrews
um podcast but it picked it up in other
places because early on
when we were putting a book together
tall Roz uh the writer uh my son
uncredited co-author so the books really
collaboration between me my son Brandon
and Tall Ross
and we're driving for that's right you
know when somebody feels like what
you've said is completely their position
they say that's right
not you're right but that's right
so tall says you know I think I think
what's Happening Here is you're
triggering a subtle Epiphany in somebody
so I'm like all right I'll buy that so I
start looking up the Neuroscience of the
feeling of epiphany
getting a hit of
oxytocin and serotonin
oxytocin is a bonding drug
you bond to me I'm about to you when you
feel completely understood by me you
bond to me
then in one of the relationship podcasts
I'm listening to on on Andrew
um it says oxytocin inclines people to
tell the truth
you're more honest all right so you feel
deeply understood by me you bond to me
and you start getting more honest with
me
serotonin
the neurochemical satisfaction
Epiphany you feel oxytocin and serotonin
being understood all right I got you
bonding to me I got you being more
honest with me and I got you feeling
more satisfied so you want less
what more do you want out of a
negotiation
of course there's already with the
leaders and great negotiators there's a
walls built up defense mechanisms
against that right there's you're
resisting
you're resisting this basic chemistry
but yes you should have that
um you should work towards that kind of
empathy
and I I personally believe I I don't
actually understand why but I've
observed it time and time again but
getting in a room together
and really talking whether privately or
publicly we're really talking
uh and like this so I'll I'll comment on
this so right now this is being recorded
and a few folks will hear this but when
you really do a good job with this kind
of conversation you forget there's
cameras right and that's much better
than there being even a third person in
the room but often when um world leaders
meet those like press or there's others
in the room like as you know man-to-man
or man to woman you have to like meet
like in like in a saloon just the two of
you and talk there's some intimacy and
power to that to achieve the the if
you're also willing to couple that with
empathy to really hear the other person
yep yep yeah I don't know what that is
that's like a deep deep intimacy that
happens and I think there's actually
because we get access in a Black Swan
group all the time like how do you you
know Zoom that's bad you know because
you don't have the same visual feedback
on Zoom yeah and that's not true like
you and I I see you from the waist up
right now if we're on Zoom I'd be
looking at you from the waist up I'm not
wearing pants yeah the internet
I apologize for that
sorry yeah yeah yeah you only see a
small portion
usually that's usually where I go but uh
anyway
I'm glad we both have ridiculous I
appreciate it
but what makes this different in person
I I actually think
um I think there's energy
that we're unable we don't have the
instrumentation to Define yet
and I think that there's a feel I think
there's an actual energetic feel that
changes and just because we don't we
again just because we can't
measure it
doesn't mean it's not there
yeah I would love to figure out what
that is uh folks that are working on
virtual reality are trying to figure out
that what that is during the pandemic
everybody was on Zoom zoom and Microsoft
everybody's trying to figure out how do
we replicate that I'm trying to
understand how to replicate that because
it sure is not fun to travel across the
world just to talk to Snowden or Putin
or zielinski I'd love to do it over Zoom
but it's not the same it's not the same
no it's not the same